besonders hart treffen die freiheits
einschränkungen aber kinder und
jugendliche seit zwei jahren inzwischen
lange zeit kein sportverein kommen
freunde treffen die schulen monate lang
dicht und jetzt jetzt rund wieder
schulschließungen heute entscheidet sich
das am abend wichtiges treffen 16
kultusministerin und minister der länder
wir sprechen mit der chefin dieser
kultusministerkonferenz mit der
schleswig-holsteinischen ministerin
karin prien schönen guten tag frau prien
können sie uns versprechen dass der
präsenzunterricht aufrecht halten bleibt
also wenn es nach mir geht ja und das
entspricht ja auch der rechtslage nach
dem bundesimmissionsschutzgesetz dass
die rechtler ist ja auch nicht so dass
flächendeckende schulschließung dadurch
habe ich gar nicht gedeckt wären
und ich bin sehr zuversichtlich dass
dieser konsens auch weiter so bestehen
bleibt ja aber das wichtigste wort ist
ja im moment quarantäne also das ist ja
schulschließung sozusagen andersrum
einem moment muss ein schüler auch dann
den quarantäne wenn er negativ getestet
ist wie müssen wir diese quarantäne
regelung jetzt lockern frau prien
erzählt dass es notwendig ist über die
frage der garantien und der isolierung
zu sprechen und zwar auch mit blick auf
das system schule
damit es zum einen darum kräfte und
andere an schule beschäftigte auch als
angehörige der kritischen infrastruktur
einzuschätzen aber ich glaube auch dass
wir in deutschland insgesamt über die
frage der quarantäne jetzt diskutieren
müssen so wünschen wir uns natürlich
eine einheitliches vorgehen auch eine
entsprechende empfehlung des robert koch
institut ist und ich bin zuversichtlich
dass da hat sich in dieser woche etwas
bewegen wird die kinder haben wir nicht
nur viel lernstoff verpassen den letzten
monaten sondern die kinder sind ja auch
einsamer geworden deren sozialen eine
menge aufzuholen denken sie in der
politik auch daran
da sprechen sie aus meiner sicht fast
den zentralen punkt an kinder und
jugendliche waren in deutschland im
besonderen maße betroffen von den
auswirkungen der pandemie kinder und
jugendliche in deutschland mussten viel
länger zu hause bleiben und waren in
ihrer entwicklung gehemmt als in anderen
ländern
und ich glaube das ist ganz entscheidend
ist kindern gemeinschaftserlebnisse im
kulturellen bereich im sportbereich in
der schule aber auch außerschulisch
weiter zu ermöglichen denn eine gesunde
entwicklung von kindern und jugendlichen
selbst voraus dass sie sich mit
gleichaltrigen gemeinsam im sport messen
musizieren sich einfach treffen danke an
schleswig-holsteins kultusministerin
karin